pour bienvenue sur diagonale tv alors
spécial match
topalov contre kamski demi finales du
championnat du monde alors topalov mène
ce match par deux victoires à une
on va voir la partie numéro 7
aujourd'hui et on reçoit pour commenter
cette partie le nouvel invité pour
diagonale t qui est déjà passé sur
l'émission c'est aurélie dacalor bonjour
aurélie on va rappeler bref vraiment on
l'a dit dans la première émission
donc tu es une joueuse d'échecs de
talent parce que tu as été plusieurs
fois championne de france chez les
jeunes et ça c'est pas donné à n'importe
qui il y en a comme par catégorie et par
an c'est peu mais ça va quoi de petits
poussins à juniors 1 voilà mon petit
poussin poussins pupilles benjamins
cadets juniors minimes cadets juniors il
ya cette catégorie dont il ya sept
champions de france mixte et cette
championne de france fille par ans avec
le 14 pour les énarques qui sont ils
sont même plus nombreux donc là c'est
plus difficile d'être champion de france
d'échecs énarque voilà alors donc tu as
été plusieurs fois championne chez les
poussins chez les mx donc tu as battu
les garçons en fait et tu as été deux
fois ou trois faux chez les filles
enfin là et tu joues si on top 12
championnats france féminin par équipes
et le top16 aussi quel top du top
aussi des matchs par équipe en france tu
as joué aussi au championnat
de france nationale on va fermer très
dur très dur
des joueuses comme sophie millet comme
mira skripchenko qu'on aime essebag et
du monde quoi alors tes copines aussi
avec peut-être d'autres joueuses qu'on a
reçues sur des modèles télécom matile
conjugaux aussi peut-être aussi way
était très bonne joueuse aussi un très
forte
la battue alors elle aussi je crois
qu'elle a battue stéphanois l'a battu
oui antoine et à stefano valla champion
du monde carrément comme quoi rien n'est
impossible
alors on va raconter avec toi c'est ce
match topalov kamski alors tu connais
ses joueurs on peut alors est ce que tu
aimes le ch'ti est ce que tu connais
leur style un peu leur histoire ou comme
tu sais pas le tu sais que comme ce qui
était parti qu'il est revenue movistar
est d'ailleurs un truc qui te concerne
on peut peut-être parce qu'il a étudié
le droit je prends voulais faire des
études de médecins ou de droit il a fait
droit en fait il a fait une voyage et
voilà parce que tu fais du droit comme
ce qui est donc été partie parce que bon
il n'arrivait pas en fait bon les
premiers son père aussi je crois
d'ailleurs son père qui était hyper
présent pour lui mais enfin bon il
arrive au top du top il a perdu un match
contre karpov il ya du bon façon art
jamais à devenir champion du monde parce
que karpov et kasparov ceci cela c'est
un peu il est parti quelques années il
est revenu égale la coupe du monde
ils se retrouvent en demi-finales faveur
du monde extraordinaire qu'on appelle un
retour gagnant ça et là elle face à
topalov donc 7e du match alors la can ce
qu'ils menaient 2 1 le match a lieu en
bulgarie chez topalov match très
important puisque le vainqueur jouera le
champion du monde vivent manhattan
allende
champion incontesté or ce premier
championnat contesté depuis 1993 et la
scission de kasparov avec la fille d
cramique avait battu caspar ans
n'étaient pas reconnus par la fidh bon
c'était quand même le vainqueur de
kasparov donc le 14e champion du monde
classique et l'a donc anand est devenu
le 15e champion du monde topalov qui est
numéro un mondial rêve sans doute de
gagner sept couronnes là parce que il a
perdu son match face à cannes ce qui est
ce qu'il va y arriver mais on sait pas
en tout cas là ils doivent battre kamski
c'est la septième du match et s'ils
gagnent ce match il joua contrat dans
nos matches sans doute explosif entre le
génie indien et peut-être donc topaloff
ou alors peut-être comme ce qui on va
voir cette septième partie topalov face
à cam ski 7e du match 2 1 pour topalov
on y va dans ce grand match de
championnat du monde demi finale donc eu
quatre pour topalov donc c'est parti
pour une ouverture ouvert donc sa
deuxième moitié du match pas mal pour 4
1 topalov a joué pas mal de cas dont 6
françaises alors une partie types de
parties qu'on a déjà vu dans la
quatrième dans la cinquième du match à
la 4ème et la 5ème du match avec
philippe dans une bouche ici sur des
modèles tv puisqu'on retour aux troubles
a vraiment arraché sykael et des deux on
sent le caler en d2 pour protéger le
pire aux quatre et non pas en c3 c3 il
peut se faire clouer par le foie de
verser évidemment ici si et noir jouent
au foot b4 on joue simplement c2 c3 et
c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau
c'est même une perte de temps à venir
donc elle est deux on protège avec ce
coup grand pas en mai
mais messieurs attention à ce genre de
coups donc ces cinq et on avait vu dans
la partie précédente les blancs avaient
répondu lancer leur convoi la
préparation pause ouverture les bleus
avaient répondu par le coût tout à fait
jouable cavaliers gf3 donc le cavaliere
3 vient protéger puis en d4 les deux
cavaliers protège les deux pions et là
c'est un autre une autre variante que
nous propose en fait topalov sans doute
pour surprendre aussi l'adversaire ça
c'est important
tu vois aussi ses défauts des coûts pour
surprendre ses adversaires
les ouvertures et c'est vrai est ce que
tu sais ce à quoi s'attend l'adversaire
pour le surprendre c'est ça pour sûr que
non bien sûr que non mais pour
surprendre
il faut aussi jouer parfois des cours
qui sortent vraiment vraiment des
sentiers battus macau et ça surprend
toujours notamment contredit pour
joueurs qui eux sont habitués à la
théorie et s'attendent à ce que je dis
d'accord donc toi même tu en fait tu
t'attends à jouer des coupes n'a pas
prévu avant même la partie d'accord ça
c'est important doté en fait joueuses
créative en fait c'est de créer du jeu
alors qu' on prend des 5 alors les
blancs les noirs videmment s'il est noir
reprennent du pillon eux et ils vont se
retrouver avec ce qu'on appelle un pion
isoler les blancs tout à reprendre sans
doute en c5 et les pions des 5 sera
isolé ce qui est un souci donc d'en
reprendre plus tôt de la dame pour
éviter cette possibilité là car les jmf
3 pour les blancs hélas les blancs c'est
à dire que sacrifice implicitement le
pion des quatre puisque les noirs
peuvent le prendre il va il s'en prive
pas et ce pion est perdu mais en échange
de quoi les blancs accélère le
développement et on sait qu'aux échecs
sur vos deux ou trois plus développement
donc il faut faire attention à pas
donner trop de coûts de développement
pour un pion fous ces quatre dames des
six petit regarder les blancs jouer un
deux trois quatre coups de développement
les colonies ouverte ici ou semi ouverte
en tout cas sur le
sur le camp ennemi et les noirs ont
sorti que la dame donc malgré le pur -
julian bon c'est pas ce soutien c'est
vraiment faudra se dire que le
développement comptent autant que les
pions vous allez voir pourquoi t'es
relief 6 tours les blancs continuent à
se développer ici un vis-à-vis
évidemment tour roi qui est toujours
très intéressant fawcett les blancs les
noirs couvre tout de suite près par le
petit rock et là regardez c'est l'heure
à laquelle il est roi regard des 1 2 3
voilà on voit tout de suite que ce
qu'ils ont et perdu les noirs évidemment
ne peuvent pas à défendre par le 5
puisque le cabinet corps et d'âme et
s'il protège y aura toujours que deux
défenseurs donc de toutes façons les
blancs avaient fait donc c'est donc
comme ceux du sacrifice théorique on va
dire que c'était extrêmement connue
alors qu a blessé six donc les blancs
saiss et leurs prénoms des cartes calais
prend des quatre pour les noirs qui
échangent l'a très vite on est quatre
être petit rock voilà donc là le
développement est terminé on voit que
les blancs petite avance de
développement intéressantes
il ya quand même voilà je vous y
concentrer une action ici sur le centre
alors à noter que c'est une position
asymétrique toujours important trois
pions ici contre 2 et de l'autre côté
par contre ici trois pions contre eux 4
donc il faut compter là où l avantage
donc les blancs ont plutôt un avantage
toutefois les dames et au centre alors
que les noms un avantage du roi mais qui
peut pas leur servir pour lancer une
attaque puisque leurs pièces sont
beaucoup trop mais c'est un thème
fondamental or le coup suivant des
blancs est intéressant c'est 3 évident
commenté govou s'est beaucoup de
consolidation sont peut-être que les
blancs ont simplement envie de s'en
doute de sortir la dame par exemple en
f3 est simplement protégé et pas
défendre avec un coup qu'on me foute roi
qui boucherait cette tour ils veulent
développer sans doute leur fou par
exemple en f4 si la dame et en f3 donc
en attaquant la dame ici voir angers 5
donc il faut donc protéger ce cavalier
des centrales c'est sans doute
tout à fait logique food et c'est
d'avoir les noirs se développe
ça c'est logique d'un bertrand c'est
leur attaque dont qui ont baissé alors
si les noirs protéger par tous et si ce
serait une faute
on prendrait simplement le fou et ça
casse il faudrait que les noirs
reprennent avec le pion et c'est pas bon
la paire de foule à faster de fond final
donc ça sera un gros avantage pour les
blancs et donc je voulais éviter ce
genre de coup évidemment
donc on protège autrement le cube et 7
ont fait dame b 6 6 très intéressant
simple et on évite éventuellement de se
faire chasser la dame par un concombre
au f4 que regagnant le temps sur la dame
donc four b3 alors ça toujours selon de
coûts très intéressant la haine un
double avantage c'est que 1
il enlève le fou d'une case où il est en
prise sur clés noires pour regagner le
temps à l'attaquant déjà c'est plus
possible et de hibou ch
aussi l'action la dalle mort sur le cube
et 2 donc on va pouvoir sortir le fouet
de cases blanches de 4 noirs ici sacré
donc le coup simon et noir s'explique
ici quand on a compris ça ouais à 5
voilà donc l'attention si je bouge le
fou avait l'intention je peux m'exposer
a beaucoup à 4 le fonds doit bouger
depuis on vient de tomber mais quand
même fou et 3 voilà donc les blancs ont
pas peur pourquoi parce qu'il crée une
contrebasse imaginons que les noirs
jouent le coup un cadre qu'est ce qui se
passe à ce que le foot doit bouger et on
perd le cuir mon nom alors que c'est
alors que ça veut dire il faudrait qu
est ce qui se passerait il passerait
peut-être
alors qu'avaient laissé alors pourquoi
mais lorsque je peux prendre le cas ici
cette attaque là alors le problème c'est
que le cavalier f5 attaque le fossé est
ça qu il faudrait défendre dans ce cas
là la dame est apte à qui faut défendre
part d'amd 8 et là on aura un problème
parce qu'il y aurait sans doute
cavaliers prendre cet échec d'un prendre
pour et maintenant ils mentent et d'en
sortir le fouet et encore plus fort
peut-être maintenant je pensais la fosse
et saigne ça marche pas le foot à
protéger donc il faudrait maintenant
sortir le fouet par exemple sous ces
deux et on à la paire de fou donc on
comprend l'idée c'est que fou et 3 on
n'a pas peur de quoi cas on peut jouer
faux droit puisque la dame est attaqué
et en fait cette l'idée c'est que cette
dame n'a pas de case parce que si elle
bouge
du coup si elle peut pas venir en bessin
qu'à cause du collier ne peux pas alors
attention
elle peut pas venir non plus en b 4 à
cause du pion c3 donc elle peut pas
rester sur cette colonne tout en étant
attaqué par le faux 3 avec la menace
câble et f5 arrivée voire même cavalier
36 aussi d'ailleurs car les principes et
ciani parce que le foot protège le
cavalier et la dame devrait d'abord par
et la menace du fou et ensuite on sortir
les cavaliers alors donc seul coup
maintenant pour les noirs c'est de jouer
c'est simple parce que sinon si la dame
sort évident de la colombe et on a plus
de problème sur la colombie est un
joueur ou c5 les noirs menace toujours à
4 c'est intéressant et bien tant pis
pour topalov c'est pas grave
tourner un quand même donc j'ai pas peur
du coup à 4 heures ils se gênent pas
évident comme ce qu'il faut savoir comme
ce qui exclut ces mené au score on est à
la 7e il est mené 2 1 donc il n'y a plus
deux parties l'a7 l'a8 pour revenir donc
il faut qu'ils prennent des risques
donc il va en profiter de ce dernier
coup droit d un pur comme ce qui pour
tenter quand même d'aller grappiller un
pion pour essayer de gagner la partie
donc ils jouent à 4 évidemment mais tous
pas la vue
ouais secoué quand même dangereux
puisque après fou ces deux dames prend
b2 évidemment les blancs ont lâché le
pion b2 mais voilà il ya une
compensation il va falloir suivre ça
c'est le coup j'ai 5
alors voilà donc fou j'essaye dans le
premier cinq c'est quoi pour le voir ses
clefs et blanc menace fou prend m6 qui
on prend avec d'un prend derrière un
endroit totalement à l'ouest
si les noirs prenez le fou des quatre on
pourrait ensuite prendre en plus de la
tour avec la tour qui viendra attaqué le
roi évidemment alors et c'est compliqué
parce que se font prendre des quatre le
fou ces deux est plus protégé mais alors
aussi les blancs on va encore montrer
les menaces parce que en sommant menace
ici aussi mais alors il ya aussi cette
menace tombe est un qui peut grappiller
le tombé c'est sans compter aussi que si
on élimine aux cavaliers 6 le fou 17 ici
peut être en prise par la tour d un donc
dès qu'on bouge le cavalier ce fou peut
sauter donc c'est très compliqué
donc on est rentré dans une phase
extrêmement tactique du jeu il faudrait
quelques calculs et quasiment toutes les
bandes alors imaginons que les noirs
jouent le coup par exemple fou prend des
cats qui est tout à fait envisageable
on est loin de l'idée évidemment c'est
ce que tu disais c'est que le fou ces
deux effectivement l'escalafon des sans
doute reprendre de la tour pourquoi
parce qu'on garde comme ça une attaque
sur le souder sets et à près d'un
profond cavaliers alors ici en plus on
peut menacer du coup ton g4 avec attaque
sur le roi menaces et orange et 7 et un
math rapide et si les noirs jour j'ai
six ils affaiblissent irrémédiablement
les cases noires avec adam g
et en plus le fou 17 et d'attaquer
langues
comment faire c'est pas évident pour les
noirs si on joue encore un coup comme
fou c'est si ça peut être intéressant
puisque on attaque la dame g3 mais on
peut encore jouer d'investissement
on avait en course à ce qu'on peut pas
jouer tour g4 iliad un grand fou voilà
donc ça c'était jouable pour les noirs
cette vente c'était compliqué mais
jouable alors au lieu de quoi ici kamski
a choisi un autre coup peut-être
peut-être mon prêt c'est finalement
peut-être que fo prend des câpres et on
était peut-être mieux au vu de cette
variante il a joué cavalier des cinq
puis l'es5 donc évidemment il n'y a plus
la menace ici ou là l'intérêt si c'est
que saint-vallier aussi est protégé par
publicis et bush l'action de cette tour
donc il est à l'air d'avoir moins de
danger et garde une menace franck
cavallier suivi d'un prof ou alors là
dessus topalov joue le coup ses cadres
alors voilà donc il crée en compte
contre menace donc on est en plein
dedans alors c'est compliqué parce que
on voit bien le câble étant prises mais
évidemment le cavalier d4 et emprise du
fou avec la dame b2 qui protège derrière
le foot c'est deux seraient en prise on
se dit mais il a raté un truc il a raté
c'est vrai il a raté un truc d'or c'est
ce que fait comme ce qu'il faut prendre
des quatre caisses cabu topalov regarder
très jolie ou intermédiaire donc ça
c'est fort dans le détroit
ça c'est fort parce qu'alors l'idée
d'amener 3 c'est que je protège le foot
bien sûr mais je venais à ce mardi au
passage donc toujours ces histoires de
menaces intermédiaires et oui ça c'est
fort donc là ici le nas matt tout
simplement d'un proche 7 maths et amath
puisque le fou protège là donc c'est la
menace ultime il faut évidemment la part
et donc les noirs ont pas le choix il
peut jouer soit g6 soit le coût de la
partie f5 qui affaiblit peut-être un peu
on a toujours peur de pousser on dit
souvent qu'on pousse le plus bref trop
tôt tu connais cet adage c'est vrai
quant à dire il faut jamais pousser les
pions et or dès maintenant alors au
pâlot choisi de prendre en d4 et les
noirs n'ont pas le choix de prendre la
dame et pour se diriger à deux pièces de
pièces parce que si les noirs font des
rondes à regarder après tout prendre on
a un problème s'il ya cavaliers fou
emprise
il faudrait jouer cavalier b6 est à
prévoir des tours bien on a des soucis
est-ce que cavalier dès qu'il bouge elf
ou 17 ans le rallye à tout et à tout est
en prison
c'est pas du tout facile voilà c'est pas
comme moi donc ça pose des vrais
problèmes donc après d'un pronom n'a pas
le choix pleinement il faut prendre le
c2 et maintenant puis on prend des 5 et
les noirs ne peuvent pas reprendre des
cinq sous peine du simple dames prendre
des cinq échecs attaque le fou 17 et si
les noirs vous le contour et 7 pour
protéger le fou évidemment il ya le
risque simple tour cette attaque à la
fois menacé dame prend tout s'est tu es
aussi tout reprendre et c'est très
difficile appareil le seul coup ce
serait je vous évite qui tient par
miracle on joue on pourrait jouer tour
c'est un menaces après deux tours c'est
cette enfin on fait un triple agent fait
c'est horrible tour ou un aussi bien sûr
effectivement je sais pas si le terme
moche et appropriée mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que c'est à dire que j'ai
fait exactement tout à fait donc ses
points des cinq donc c'est pas simple
pour mémoire ici donc là comme ce qui
tente un autre coup ces dames 3 2 en
fait c'est intéressant l'idée évidemment
c'est que surtout on prend 1,6 on peut a
priori on prend du fou puisque la dame à
deux protège cabu topalov là dessus ça
c'est important d'indécis ça c'est joli
ça c'est joli alors l'idée de d'un v6
c'est de dire en fait peut pas on peut
pas prendre ici et aux menaces au
contraire ont menacé si de prendre en
russie avec la dame qui protège et la
cour donc de protection
l'abbé un pion énorme puisque là aussi
c'est plus qu'à jouer cet essai c'est
fini ça serait terrible un v6 et fort si
les noirs joué le coup si on prend des
cinq qui a l'air de dire je résous ça
résout les problèmes bien tout
simplement on peut jouer en pro b cette
attaque le fou 17 et menaces dam dom au
tour prend des singles et aussi pourquoi
pas tours 7
on peut pas jouer tous rêvent s'être non
plus qu'il serait intéressant parce que
la torah 8 serait en prison
donc c'est très très délicat pour les
noirs ce superbe coup ici d'auto pas
l'offre d'un v6 comme ce qui finalement
laisse les choses en l'état et se dit
bon mais je vais essayer de calme des
troupes contre agen contre le parce que
là on a quand même pu repasser protéger
ce pur sélection menace d'aller dame
évidemment ça peut être très paralysant
pour les noirs donc à trois ils poussent
pour l'instant parce que les landes
menace pas non plus de mettre
directement dans des tours sète fawcett
pardon de la part des de la part des
blancs l'âge active le fou alors l'idée
de jouer cette saison et a finalement je
vais pouvoir pousser ses pions il sera
protégé par le fou et en plus le fou
contrôle toujours là la case qu'on
appelle la casse de promotion donc là où
le et appeler ça c'est paralysant pour
une fossette
il faut jouer la tour ont pas laissé la
qualité du positionnement des tours 8 et
à regarder d'amd 6 la dame bien protégé
fou et attac ou 17 qui alluma l'unc a du
mal à trouver à une case spectre aussi
le but de secours à trois peut-être de
recycler sur l'a 4 à 4 ça peut être
aussi l'idée évidemment le fou on va
pouvoir venir là alors on peut en plus
qu'on est la question est ce que les
noirs pourraient jouer le coup tout à
fait fou c'est 8 qui mais c'est très
passif on voit bien que le flou doit
revenir à la maison
on ad on avait signalé aussi mais bon
les noirs peut notamment peuvent
envisager pourquoi pas de prendre de
prendre des cinq minutes comme c'est à
nous je crois que c'est nous qui allons
prendre éventuellement dans ce cas là on
prendra un dessin un peu comme dans wii
parce que surtout reprend il ya tout
reprend i mate et c'est un échec et mat
donc il faut faire très attention c'est
très tactique sa série je serai tactile
une autre possibilité aussi s'il joue le
coup j'ai entraînement des dames c'est 7
avec l'idée des 6-17 et si les noirs
prennent ici on vous le regardez le
superbe fou et 6 c'est énorme
parce qu'on menace regardez en menace
maths et il ya aussi tout un pan 8 qui
menacent maths et s'il est noir
évidemment je suis pas là que je prends
aussi je prends tout reprendre prendre
menace toujours de maths pour la et d'un
promat on peut pas parler d'eux avant de
donner du matériel donc donc c'est chaud
alors donc toi et celui d'anne decis ça
pose un souci donc kamski donc refus
cette variante plus on n'a pas envie de
jouer tout s'est vite aussi
il comprend parce que comme toi ouais on
n'a pas envie de retourner nous l'avons
bien ça c'est clair
donc fou à 4 mais c'est peut-être que
c'est peut-être quand même le mieux à
jouer malgré tout enfin catherine
ouattara attaquent le tout la tour des
hommes et on a toujours la possibilité
aux déchets clients de faire un taux
intermédiaire quand on est attaqué
surtout quand ce coup intervenir fait
échec donc d'en prendre
échec et ça y est on a un pion passer
tout seul parce qu'une fois qu'on a une
mine espions échec au roi des infos par
un échec
moi je suis efforcé et aura t on un pion
qui peut aller à dame direct alors
attention tout de suite puisque la dame
à 2 s'échangeraient et le froid cap
tiendrait sans doute le pion en respect
ici donc voilà peu plat se pressent pas
ils jouent tour à un attaque déjà la
dame à 2 et aux vastes d'am dam c4 la
dame reste sur la diagonale blanche
parce qu'elle veut pas permettre on peut
permettre six en tout cas de permettre
en échange des dames et après le fou
veiller à 1,17 et on a bloqué ce fameux
pions passé puis nous mêmes on a deux
pions ici intéressant ça serait une
erreur donc les blancs harcèle la dame
ça c'est important
ou alors si elle reste sur la blanche on
va sans doute peut-être avait grappillé
puis ont baissé
et oui parce que si elle était venu
effectivement on va montrer ça oui c'est
bien vu c était venu en b3 on aurait
sans doute mais on peut jouer tour a333
puisque le fou au sed protège et après
dada mais protéger elle-même donc ça
marcherait pas donc tour dames ces
quatre là d'un pas de cas si on vit en
b3 top 3 le fou protège et donc fou ces
deux voilà on fait la même chose qui se
passe ici abordé le fou empêche la tour
de prendre la dame et là on fait pareil
le fou empêche de prendre la main alors
ça c'est important de le juge cette
position là où on est quand même au lit
de façon générale alors comment je vide
qui al'avantage c'est pas clair parce
qu'on a trois pions ici contre 3 ici les
noirs ont bien deux pions passé les
passes il y est
alors ils sont pas tout à fait lit est
sûre il faudra qu'il avance un peu pour
lier presque livre enfin casini sont
liés potentiellement il faudrait que
vous avez 4 is really est vraiment quoi
mais ils sont vraiment plus physiquement
liés et les blancs suis par contre ce
gros pions des 520 qui lui aussi est pas
loin de la promotion qui possède t
mobiliser parce que si on pense ce qui
me passait bien assez soutenue mais on
est bloqué et quoi les bloquer alors
c'est pas évident de devoir qui
al'avantage topalov va montrer qu'en
fait c'est lui qui a davantage marqué
par des coups très précis il faut pas se
tromper
en tout cas des coups agressifs notament
attention quand même parce que ces deux
ça fait peur moi je pense que les noirs
sont même un peu mieux dans cette
position alors évidemment topalov
l'agressif alors il a une pièce passé
mais aura des champions à trois aussi
passé mais bon la différence voire décès
que là les blancs contrôler la casse de
promotion alors qu'ici pas du tout voilà
le fouillent socquettes blanches et là
tout bloc
voilà le seul truc c'est que si les
noirs et joue à jouer b5 bk placé là ça
deviendrait inquiétant est très
difficile donc ici d'un essai l'idée
séduit dans de permettre des six là il
ya plus d'un probable
et en plus sur la tac au passage on
attaque aussi le pion à 2 et des six
soit c'est l'heure maintenant ça on
appelle ça un
comme on l'appelle d'ailleurs moi non
plus mais à vrai dire ça ce soutien très
bien voilà ça voilà le pion soutient le
fouet le foot est allé soutien mutuel
voilà ça c'est important c'est la
cohésion cohésion sociale des pièces
lesquels des pièces d'échecs et
potentiellement votre bien que des dames
aura joué par 17 avec aux fous qui
contrôle toujours cette caste de
promotion c'est faux et là donc les
noirs seller dans ce qu'on a dit il faut
jouer aussi leur avantage donc là les
blancs doivent jouer extrêmement précis
s'ils veulent pas tomber dans deux
paires dans cette partie ça peut aller
très très vite puisque b5
voilà donc la menace des noirs ckoi et
4,3 et b2c ali c'est fini parce que même
si le pion coups sont bons sacrifie une
pièce pour le pion et puis nous on a
récupéré une tour et on a encore un pion
passé c'est l'avantagé en avoir deux
alors dame bessette de la part de la
part des blancs alors l'idée sans doute
c'est que si les noirs du v4 voilà
essayer dès cette année que l'idée si la
tour enfin si on attaque ici à la fois
le tombé 4 et il a tourné cette alors où
va la tour si par exemple un tour vient
dé 8
on peut faire échec avec dame échec et
surtout prend on peut envisager un
simple d'un point b 4 par exemple
voilà donc on peut récupérer on peut
récupérer le pion mais il ya quand même
un engagement à cause de ce pion oui
donc
là les noirs auraient sans doute eu
intérêt à jouer b4 dans cette position
au lieu de quoi comme ce qu'ils jouent
tous eu des huit qui est peut-être un
tout petit peu imprécis bien vite c'est
mon principe est ce qu'on est ce qu'on
ne dit pas souvent
aurélie d'ailleurs que quand on allait
au pas s'il faut les pousser parce
qu'ils ont tendance à non seulement a
menacé de faire nommer à bloquer
l'adversaire en défense vie parce qu'ils
sont obligés de mobiliser leurs pièces
pour éviter qu'on aille adam donc ça
enlève des pièces l attaque qu'on est en
train de mener forcément donc là qu'elle
soit comme ceux qui auraient oublié
c'est cette règle de base
or je crois pas qu'elle qui est oublié
mais il a dû commettre sa précision ce
qui peut arriver donc tous les jouets
tourbe et 8
alors c'est intéressant aussi parce
qu'on dit souvent si les tours doivent
être derrière les pions passé parce
qu'évidemment il disait da lapa la
poussée sauf que là il ya quand même un
pion qui peut dévier cette tour à tout
moment décider 7 et des buts dame sera
une menace perpétuelle
donc il faut faire attention donc ici
dames c'est 7 de la part d'auto parole
l'intérêt de ces sept c'est que vient
ainsi d'apprendre hamon prend du pion et
là tout est attaqué on gagne en quittant
sans compter qu'il est le tout le foot
on perdrait le fou en fait et les noirs
ne peuvent pas jouer des quatre à cause
de d'en prendre
et d'ailleurs même on peut supposer oui
la menace aussi c'est d'un programme
puisque le foot c'est de se ré perdent
donc là c'est vraiment embêtant ce qu'a
joué c'est un bon coup de défense alors
c'est pour ça que le coup sans doute ici
b4 étaient plus précis qui tu en voilà
pour kamski dans cette position et
100000 gagnant sur la variante sans
doute la plus tendue 17 tout simplement
maintenant ont joué tout au 8
c'est pas pareil parce qu'on peut plus
jouer dame c7 est donc ici sur des huit
dames afrique tout simplement pour
prendre et saufs au grand dam simplement
tout reprend et on a ici deux pions
passé lié dame soutenu la tour des huit
pieds en défense pour éviter les mêmes
du court
donc avec dès qu'on a joué b3 en plus
tous tiers là aussi et oui non mais dès
qu'on a joué trois parties
elle est finie pour les noirs donc elle
a donc erreur de gamme ce qui est ce
niveau là donc très important tournant
du match parce que comme ce qui doit
quand même essayer d'égaliser pour
revenir dans le match et à ce moment là
il joue tourbe et huit au lieu de jouer
ce coupé quatre très fort donc peut-être
mon image on donne ses sept tours c8 de
la part des noirs voilà donc la regarder
cette donc on avait dit la menace un
mail à évidemment si dimpre en avons
fait tout reprend et hop tout de suite
le fouet de nouveaux protégés n'y a pas
de problème donc c'est ce que font quand
même les bains n'y a pas le choix
un tour prend on protège de nouveaux
fouet la différence c'est que maintenant
de 17 et on va faire d'art on va
récupérer quelque chose donc ça c'est ça
c'est embêtant
les mouches ont changé d'âne en quelque
sorte parce que même si les noirs pouces
on peut envisager que les blancs mais du
coup face aux sacrifices et l'iman
qu'ils ont récupéré une tourbe et ils
vont récupérer du matériel
sans compter que son proche du gain du
match puisqu'il ya plus deux parties
celle là est la dernière à longer une
très lourde four b3 d'un fou fou bien la
part de 2k mme schick et sans doute
l'erreur finale ici il faut bien calés
rebond parce qu'on se dit effectivement
ça a l'air pas mal parce que si dame fou
prend tous reprendront jouber 4 et après
b3 à b2 on se dit que le food et 8
pourra pas venir un f6 contrôle et b2 il
n'a pas tout vu parce que tout reprend
non pas tout reprendre il a joué tour d
un ici topalov que n'avait sans doute
pas vu comme ce qui menace de faire
damer de gagner une tournette et le foot
garde le contrôle sur b4 et en plus
sombre menace mat
il faut jouer aux perdants avec roger
huit dames échec regarder et surtout
reprend fou prend ça c'est malin et
regarder l'idée de l'autopsié dira mais
attention moi je me lasse tout
simplement tout reprend fou et après
tout reprendre j'ai une pièce de plus
c'est un pion tu pourras parler
d'impasse que je contrôle très bientôt
et qui font donc à ça oblige comme ce
qui a essayé de trouver des astuces avec
issifou ses deux meilleurs dès
maintenant le problème c'est qu'ils
lâchent le pion le pion le pion à deux
tours d'essai un clouage ici sur les
deux ça tient plus il arrive plus à
pousser ses pions à db4 ici contre on
peut être totalement kamski ici tout
reprend à deux ont regardé ça y est
hyper le pur à 2 c'est fini parce que
même en sacrifiant les blancs ont pas de
problème me sacrifier une tour contre le
fou on voit bien qu'ils ont une pièce de
plus donc c'est tromper comme ce qui
dans son calcul prenant le rater b3 les
tours à huit ans plus tôt pas le fait
précis jusqu'au bout hier dès maintenant
sur b2 en l astuce tout simplement fou
et 6 échec au roi faut parer les chèques
et le fou ensuite va gober qui ont
baissé une défense parle attaque une
contre attaque et l'idée de jouer tous
ravis de il faut que les noirs protège
de cette attaque et après on va jouer la
tour en b vite et on va contrôler par
derrière l'occurrence qui est la
meilleure des défenses donc ici royal 7
et bardé tout simplement tombée voilà
c'est fini
ouais pourquoi parce que cette case et
sur noir on voit bien et le fou ils
contrôlent que les cases blanches jamais
les noirs pourront contrôler la classe b
2 pour pousser ses pions
la tour a aucun moyen fort et faire le
tour même en faisant tout on va pas trop
mal
il ya une tour entière donc là il joue
encore un peu comme ce qui parce que
c'est la fin du match si personne ne l'a
donc tout un échec pour l'honneur dans
des cinq fausses et à tisser sans doute
à ce moment là qu'il a raté un truc
malheureusement pour lui et l'a regardé
superbe foulée suite ça c'est beau parce
que évidemment sur tora 2 quelles idées
de keynes qui encourt de proposer b2 et
b1 d'essayer de récupérer du matériel
alors en jouant fuite souffrent g7 et ça
y est ça tient à sa rencontre la même
enquête en trois la case b2 on n'a plus
peur avec la tourbe et 8 et le fuji 7 on
peut pas pousser v2 et surtout racette
qui protège la classe g 7
le problème c'est qu'on contrôle plus b2
avant l'idée c'est de dire je vais jouer
le roi là et après je pousse sauf que
tranquille n'a pas peur topalov qui joue
à acheter apprécié terminé abandon elle
n'a pas trop de joueurs s'ils jouent ici
peut tenter de
il peut tenter d'avancer mais simplement
jouer des coudes toro set et après on va
faire comprendre g7
c'est fini on contrôle la casse g2 et
s'est terminée en jouant h 4 on empêche
le coup le mât du couloir en fait donc
raté pour kramnik pour au crâne lisse
décidément mais j'ai dit non mais c'est
le cas il ya quand même ça finisse a
fini par ace et un deux syllabes ses
chroniques et l'autre mais comme ce qui
est américain
la différence n'est pas
voilà donc voilà pour ce match fini à ce
moment là du match puisque 3 1 pour
autant pas là il reste une partie donc
pas la peine de jouer la dernière donc
totalement je voulais face à l'inde ça
c'est la fin de l'année ça va être un
match ça tu vois la suisse l'espagne et
le championnat du monde féminin
je suis aussi un peu ou pas tu as vu
quelqu'un derniers n'ont alors c'est
kosteniuk est battu c'est la chinoise
est-ce que tu suis où il fallut c'est la
petite tu as regardé un peu c'est parti
ouais bon tu pense qu'elle va on la voit
arriver au niveau du judit polgar ce que
tu crois pas c'est impossible dit oui
oui parce que ses 15 ans je crois en
2000 déjà 2000 presque 2006 et oui c'est
un peu significatif à cet âge là d'avoir
ce niveau je pense qu'elle a quand même
de belles années devant elle - peut-être
bien
cliché à ces âges là que vraiment on
progresse on intègre bien les choses et
en plus de ça elle a tout le temps pour
progresser davantage donc c'est super
alors on va rappeler aussi que tu donnes
des cours d'échecs à paris donc
uniquement aux membres de ton club ou
aussi à d'autres événements les écoles
de paris aussi pour faire ça dans les
écoles mais tu fais ça en le soir
comment ça va après mon travail
ouais
et puis occasionnellement chez des
familles qui ont demandé de venir comme
ça un peu actuellement étaient
disponibles étaient disponibles pour
ceux qui voudraient suivre des cours à 8
en août ont voté dans ton agenda sont
les foules n'est pas fini il est
adaptable mais disons que c'est alors
comment on fait si on veut avoir des
cours d'eau rayé d'accueil torride est
d'accord pour apprendre à jouer aux
échecs
comment on fait c'est impossible ça il
faut joindre lutèce échec est donc le
btc chèque on trouve sur internet c'est
ça le pire ces chèques ou éventuellement
on appelle la fédération puisque la
fédération aussi à tes coordonnées
d'occident
éventuellement si vous voulez donc vous
êtes sur paris vous voulez suivre des
cours avec aurélie qui donne des cours
sur paris pourquoi pas mais vous appelez
la fédération du tc chèque vous aurez
des cours sur vous avez vu toutes les
subtilités du jeu d'échecs que koné
aurélie et les techniques et voyez la
créativité regardé l'émission qu'on a
fait sur aussi sur la partie numéro 4 ou
aurélie montre sa partie aussi qu'elle a
gagné face aux grands maîtres
féminin almira skripchenko multiple
champion de france et aurélie a gagné
voyez donc c'est pas n'importe quel
professeur pour apprendre à progresser
aux échecs vous expliquera ce qu'il faut
faire et ne pas faire
merci aurélie d'être venus sur des roses
altérée si on espère le revoir sur le
plateau d'un grand pas merci beaucoup je
vous dis au revoir et à bientôt et merci
nous est fidèle sur diagonale tv voix